Negolace blood tests are advertised as a way to track cancer.
Is this test something you could use to track cancer
or reoccurrence?
One of the pros and cons of relase testing,
some clinics use it, but also read research
that can't be reproduced any thoughts on this.
Well, there's pros and cons to every test.
So there's different negolace tests that are out there.
There's the reds negolace test that you could run
with different clinics and that is sent over
to Europe to run it.
None, there are any negolace tests done in the United States.
So that is sent over to Europe for that test.
We have never, I don't know, not about it
because I don't run that test.
I, when we were looking into it,
I saw too many inconsistency, so we didn't,
we just didn't, I just didn't get into it.
I just didn't feel good about it for many reasons.
I can't remember all of them.
There was a person that I know well that uses it
another practitioner, and she really thinks the best of it,
but she is not a licensed in any way.
So she has the no ability to run any other blood work.
So that was kind of her go-to thing.
I don't think it is, but I don't think it's very accurate.
Then there's that test that you can send over to vanilla.
That's a different test similar to the negolace test,
but then there in COVID, that became extinct
because they weren't accepting any more new tests
because they were inundated with testing.
Now I don't know.
Somebody asked a question about that test
a month or so ago, and they were gonna check
and see if they're accepting any new tests.
Now I do think that test, though it seemed even more
hokey-poky was actually more accurate.
And that was simply by a making that assumption
based upon experience, not based upon any research,
because I don't think there's any research on that test.
That's a urine test.
I don't know if that is up and running.
Again, you do that test in your home.
That's the Navarro HCG test, but I don't know if that
what is up and running again.
Now that would give you a reading of zero to a hundred,
anything over 50 is positive for cancer.
It doesn't tell you what type of cancer.
And it's kind of like a tumor marker test.
And it's just every years throughout all the 25 years
and dealing with cancer patients,
that test was like correct everybody that did it.
So I was impressed with that test.
And when people were getting better via their symptoms,
via evidence on CT scans and PET scans,
and they would run that Navarro test,
the number would come down.
And you didn't give any data unto yourself.
So there wasn't any bias or anything.
So it was just it ran perfectly with other testing.
So I was very impressed with that test.
The negative of it was that you had to send it over
to the Philippines to get red.
And it took like two to two to four weeks
to get your results back.
The positive was so inexpensive.
I think it was like 55 bucks.
I don't know what it is now.
Again, I don't know if it's up and running again.
So somebody wants to check into the Navarro test.
The Nagolace test, again, I'm not against them
and it can be another marker.
But like any test you measure it on a graph,
but you measure it from over time.
And you can see the changes over time,
but it may be accurate.
I just we haven't run enough of them to really dull.
And I haven't had enough people do it
to really make a proper assessment
whether I think it was good or not.